أمس تقسيم 24 فبراير
اتخذت القوات الروسية المحمولة جوا
تحت السيطرة الكاملة للأراضي في المنطقة
محطة تشيرنوبيل للطاقة النووية مع أفراد عسكريين
كتيبة أمنية منفصلة وهناك
محطات توليد الطاقة في أوكرانيا قد وصلت
ترتيب الضمانات المشتركة
سلامة وحدات الطاقة والتابوت
تشيرنوبيل
محطة للطاقة النووية
الخلفية المشعة في المنطقة مع أمر طبيعي
أفراد المحطة يواصلون الخدمة
منشآت الطاقة النووية العادية
وضع ومراقبة المشعة
العمل المشترك
مظلات روسية وأوكرانية
الأفراد العسكريون في كتيبة حماية محطة الطاقة النووية
الدفاع هو ضمان أن
تلك التشكيلات القومية أو
المنظمات الإرهابية الأخرى
سوف تكون قادرة على استخدام
الوضع السائد في البلاد ل
منظمات الاستفزاز النووي